hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
a new free-to-play battle royale game
became available today before you think
oh no not another be our shooter you
should stick around in two because the
darwin project offers something
completely different and I'll run you
through everything you need to know
let's get the basics out of the way
first yes this is battle royale so that
means only one person can win but unlike
almost all other be ours this game only
has ten contestants and the main focus
of the game is survival we have a
temperature gauge on screen to
constantly monitor as it depletes in the
snowy sub frozen wilderness
that's where knocking down trees comes
in but unlike fought night
no one will be cranking 90s here the
wood is here to craft campfires to
replenish our temperature gauge and stop
us from freezing to death this speeds up
the game as nobody can camp
so those afks won't be in this battle
royale we have to move and we have to
play smart so what about the fighting
mechanics in the darwin project they're
very simple they're really our primary
weapons are your axe and bow but to use
the boat you'll need to craft arrows
after cutting down those trees and
that's pretty much it there are no
combos to learn there are no overpowered
weapons reliant on RNG look arrows and
axe fights that's what we do here fights
can be extremely quick over in a few
blows but from experience they can last
minutes using an axe attack at the same
time as somebody else results in both
blades clashing pushing each fighter
apart making some battles like a game of
chess fainting an attack to find an
opening to time the perfect hit through
the longer the fight prolongs the more
aware of your temperature you will
become which leads to many fights being
fought around a campfire as heat is just
as important as damaging your opposition
this is the perfect time to introduce
the three classes available in the
darwin project jet wings grappling
gauntlets
and headhunter drones each have two
further abilities to choose from in the
game lobby the Jets allow players to use
flight and verticality in their play
style grapple allows for quick traversal
and grabbing enemies at distance and the
headhunter drone has the ability to
track enemies and it'll even cut down
trees for you it's best to try each of
these for yourself as there are many
abilities to queues and unlock too many
for this video anyway for example the
grapple class has an over shield which
lasts a few seconds perfect for people
who just want to straight-up get in
there and get fighting the drone has an
invisibility perk allowing you to
conceal yourself and get the edge that
way and finally the wings can suddenly
jump away from battle and come crashing
down - there are tons more so try them
all out
[Music]
let's talk about crafting as it's one of
the most important areas in the Dow in
project it changes the game there are
two materials you'll be collecting would
like you've seen to craft arrows and
campfires and darwinian which is used to
access your abilities when holding r1
the top half of the wheel is wood
focused and the lower is darwinian using
a single piece of wood you can craft a
bear trap which will injure and
immobilize whoever stands on it and when
all else fails and there's no wood
around crap the snowball and use it to
bring down their body temperature the
key crafting ability from wood is
arguably the shield after taking down
five trees a shield may be constructed
which will take the first hit to your
face in combat hugely important when
facing equal opposition that extra hit
may be the difference between losing and
winning epically like this all on this
chapter come on come on it does on the
lower side of the circle are your class
abilities whatever you chose in the
lobby screen can be selected here as
long as you have the darwinian on hand
and now comes the depth and also how to
get another edge in battle each and
every time you can afford a darwinian
upgrade take it upgrading your axe lets
you hit harder in a fight and upgrading
your abilities can decrease the cooldown
wait to use it again or it may add
multiple uses of the same ability such
as your grappling hook simply put if
you're not in a fight get upgrading your
equipment for the edge in the next
battle the survival element of the
Darwin project also allows for hunting
for literal and metaphorical reasons
there are robot deer to take down here
in return for health and other goodies
of like a tripwire but the hunting is
also a key mechanic when searching for
enemies have you ever played a game and
you just simply cannot find anyone to
fight well that doesn't happen here in
the Darwin project every time we cut
down a tree or take some Darwinian we
leave behind a clue for another player
if another player searches that spot
they will be able to see your position
you will be highlighted on the map and
on the screen for the next few seconds
you'll also be told on screen so don't
worry too much
in fact I've noticed that it's actually
easier to follow
foot prints that way the person doesn't
know that you're on their trail
inevitably you will die in the darwin
project and that's where another cool
mechanic is found like you'd expect
upon elimination you will be spectating
another player usually the person who
murdered you will get this you have
complete control over the camera watch
from third person or move the camera
around to watch at any angle it's a
great learning experience watch the
people who win live see what decisions
they make use it to improve your own
play style I'm a sucker for a cinematic
camera so this is probably a bigger deal
to me than it is to anyone else but if
you don't want to watch it don't worry
about it get yourself out the game and
getting another one straight after you
don't have to wait until the end if you
don't want to another great and
potentially awful thing in the Darwin
project is proximity chance great for
getting to know other competitors and
making the game feel more organic and
hearing a voice as it gets closer is
great but yeah we have to talk about the
other side of it it can open up a gate
of toxicity and toxic behavior look
we've all been there world gamers we've
all got frustrated and said something
unpleasant it's all good we all not to
move on from things like that at some
point though you will encounter the scum
of the earth you've likely met in h1z1
[Music]
you know what I bet he's a nice guy
outside of his bedroom anyway when that
undoubtedly happens to you realise that
there is a report function to get these
people out of this game we are in charge
of our own community here get rid of the
ones who don't deserve to be here move
on from people like that and concentrate
on the great people you meet I run into
the same players a few times in my first
session and we all remember each other
worst case scenario mute everyone best
case scenario you may meet a new friend
I personally love proximity chat but
yeah you got to take the rough with the
smooth FYI touch the touchpad to mute
yourself and unmute dudes our favor
don't chew down your mic it's so
annoying and we don't want to hear your
mum shouting in another room
another unique concept in the Darwin
project comes straight from The Hunger
Games Movies a director let's look at
that if you're watching this and
thinking this isn't the game for me just
wait up a minute this one could be it
there is in fact an 11th player in a
typical round of the Darwin project this
person cannot win and they cannot kill
anyone well they can but just not
directly yo you'll see they have a
specific set of skills to run the match
utilizing a deck of cards the director
can help contestants by offering things
like word our campfire heat a great
director I met online gave word to
anyone who won a one-on-one in the early
game what a good way to reward be on the
flip side though the director can derail
a player's game in one game the director
deliberately closed the section I was in
every time that was fun it's okay I
ought ran the start on one another
director would drop nukes to instantly
kill anyone who wasn't quick enough to
react when I saw this I knew I had to be
on the receiving end of this here's what
it looks like when you are nuked from
close range
[Music]
the director has the same free camera
ability as we just talked about so they
can see anyone in the game they also
have proximity chats or they can talk to
everyone in the game if they so want to
I had a blast pretending hours a
real-life shoutcaster and with the
prospect of custom games this is going
to be epic inviting 10 friends to play
and directing their battles this will
give the game longevity and me for one
I'll be running custom games with my
discard family as soon as I can
I'll likely make a video about it too if
you're hearing all this and you're still
not sure if you want to do this maybe
it's the competitive play you don't want
to jump into straightaway don't worry
there is good news for you there is a
training mode with bots and AI
controlled enemies to face to keep you
away from online play until you feel
completely up to it practice your
fighting style switch up your load outs
all from the safety of AI enemies
ranging from easy to hard in difficulty
and finally let's look at cosmetics yet
they are here in the Darwin project
those spandex onesies hunt for everyone
like it expect some are paid just like
in fortnight and other PR games and some
are unlocked through playing each time
we level up a gift from our funds will
be waiting for us
this could have something inside from
shoes to assured from shoulder pads to
whatever the heck this thing is play to
unlock customization and make your
character look however you want it to so
there we have it 10 things you should
know about the Darwin project I really
hope you give this a try I think there
is the start of something brilliant here
I really do I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]